hello and welcome to this video playing
a bird Eric Lauren yeah and a rating
favorite doesn't happen so often I don't
want to be known you know not at this
time of day rather Singlish opening
against the bird and I know a place that
well and I don't so this could be tricky
minus five is my squad that's not great
okay yeah so here white basically claims
that the bishop Pam gives enough
compensation might be true might not be
true it would help if I knew it a bit
better okay the bishop on the tool looks
bad so I'm going to put it back here
five couldn't be 3985 that's not good
okay the good thing about this position
is that this Bishop on g2 is pretty
strong so it's hard to imagine that why
does in any immediate danger with such a
strong piece okay so I can't let's do
this
Quincy 7 who simply wants to keep this
it's an island c4 I mean how to play
here interesting see if I possibly maybe
just rope you one I check the pawn yeah
if I could back and it still has his
pressure there or he has to face this
pressure let's put it that way okay what
to do now I can go to be six of our like
okay let's not spend more time and play
it yeah the long diagonal pressure still
should count for something
and I have stuff like night before to d5
and the bishop a three ok so let's see
Bishop comes in I definitely want to
activate this night I didn't see nights
you for them trapping my rook but it
seems he also didn't have it on the
agenda if i take now I saw last night
see form and would be seven that's not
going to be enough ok I have to check
with this I'm not happy about it but I
think I have to so okay so he allows me
to take on b7
yeah I think I'll just yeah I can just
take take a tooth this is this something
absolutely nothing and
hmm here
I don't see and see something great
though it is really a bit for this move
but I didn't see anything remotely
promising okay
55 is that an issue I don't know an
issue is that I've spent time in a bit
of a useless way I didn't I didn't
really make the best out of this I think
there were chances to be better I don't
want to play you three here see I can
provoke f6 then try to do something on
the seventh Lucas active I don't want to
III looks looks wrong in principle
anyway hmmm let's do it let's play it
anyway the a porn is also not just
promoting my bishop is and we should ban
ruckus doing a good job here
you can just take C 3 because of the
bloody back row inmate how would y'all
take doing a good job here screwing this
up maybe it's still okay b5 would be
five okay so this is hanging now
you
okay not happy about it what can you do
them and you can play better that's
always an option but it didn't work out
in this game for me Oh interesting I
didn't expect time morning
maybe can sadly this one ambitious
reform and blundering everything what a
terrible terrible way of playing check
no idea why he put himself into this pin
check
actually not so easy now
check it's not not easy to win really
isn't check this is the rook what black
resigns Wow oh my goodness as one of the
most undeserved wins ever I just played
this like a total [ __ ] okay I think
this is okay and here I should be in
some decent shape I mean the bishop is
just so strong on g2 but yeah no I don't
know computer wants to play night see to
immediately and don't not the Rope move
for this happens I go here and now I
have this guy this is notoriously
difficult to play he is ok I guess I
actually blundered this but I think this
is probably not so bad when the engine
agrees I have very decent compensation
here 97 as a strong thread it's hard to
not return the exchange get this one
yeah this is probably equal but I played
it so badly that that he got a better
position especially III years absolute
absolutely terrible you're here I just I
don't know I can play rook c7 there's
absolutely no reason to blunder that
prom yeah yeah i was still i mean okay
here here this is winning who beat you
it's a double threat and i also think
this might win but this is something
that you probably don't want to
check it's funny how that somehow this
position is not easy maybe this is
actually a draw I mean the king if you
give you move the King it gives the
gives it porn it is pinned I don't see a
way for also that there is no there's no
way check I think Jack I think he has no
way forward but ok this is no
alternative giving up the rook it
sometimes has the same problem that I
have doesn't want to make a draw if the
opponent played like a [ __ ] earlier
then you want to win at all costs and
then you sometimes do something
something stupid like this he has the
same issue that I have ok thanks for
watching